avi - quand t'as pas loin de 50 ans
ouais on va faire une petite île perdue
check up c'est le top
ouais alors la taille c'est toujours un
mètre quatre-vingt ça ça change pas
beaucoup j'en ai vu un peu un le poids
était toujours à 85
non non vous auriol 1 et à combien
lorsqu'on bon je suppose
on n'a rien pour ça l'est dans sa vallée
d'aure bowles ont toujours pas méchant
un kit tanagra gagne origine alors j'en
ai deux qui m'ont fait très heureux
quelques années que j'ai fait changer et
alors depuis et c'est marrant je marche
mieux à il ya pas eu de rejet les
cheveux ça va c'est incroyable rayon vin
on a toutes tes cheveux les très belle
chevelure
quel est ton secret
quel est ton secret c'est assez
incroyable 9 mois je suis prof les yeux
comment ils vont tes petits dieux ils
vont mal et où wall parce qu'il écoute
et moi ma chère madame
j'aime beaucoup ce que j'aime beaucoup
vos chaussures et élégante mais quand
même non c'est vrai que dans les yeux ça
va prendre combien tu sais à peu près
les numéros non vous pour se voir mon
enfance entre ceux entre le chien et la
cage mais ça va certainement voyant et
aveugle voilà une activité sexuelle un
ralentissement depuis atteint comme dit
willy à rennes la dernière fois c'était
dans la lah reste au dessus de la
liberté c'est une dame quand même ouais
téléopération toit deux opérations de bt
juteux perreux de la jambe
ouais enfin rien de spécial c'était
varices
ouais et alors ça va maintenant des
pétards et au pea je pense qu'on se pose
plus donc ça m'a écouté
enfin dans le temps prendre le sens mais
les valaisans des ongles son tt arrange
pas les angles non non non je mange les
peaux parce que on peut mettre des
produits dessus donc nous croyons que
les zombies c'est un petit peu dur est
ce que tu as des maladies chroniques non
non on n'a pas des marsouins pourquoi
j'ai vu leurs noms mais pour savoir
enfin check up des énergies non à part
aux éditeurs telle est un peu d'énergie
ça non mais dans la tension animateur
télé d'abord sais pas mais qui est un
passe-temps tous amusez vous bien et
steve état des rues des virus non alors
par l'ansa mais maintenant tu es très
cocooning finalement pas ce que je
disais l'autre jour un article le
concernant qui avait été écrit au début
des années 60
ouais et alors ils étaient tous en train
de se déchirer et tout et toi tu étais
avec françoise à noisy-le-sec dans sa
petite maison le petit temps faisait pas
web
le fait que
jardé des journaleux emmerdeur viennent
vous voir donc si on est tranquille
ils ont rien à raconter à huy donc ça
permet de faire toutes les conneries
view on sent qu on vous emmerde skis
contre importants et les enfants ils
sont casés ça va à cause de ça j'en sais
rien ce exactement il va eddy médy votre
vie un vrai eddie lui son vrai nom et
doudou comment ça va bien il va être
traduit ainsi on va mais là ça va tout
ça bien que vivant
ça va être fait aisément bureaux
distants merci le tabac médiatique
devient la par jour je suis à moins de
deux paquets d'avants
ouais c'est bien conservés dans bones
forte dans ma main mais pourquoi mais je
sais pas parce que tu as pris un moment
où d'autres substances un peu plus
illicites quand même non oui mon faux
trop fragile une interview tu disais une
petite l'insee bien avant d'aller chez
guy lux après c'est du luxe comprend non
mais c'est vrai non mais enfin bon j'ai
jamais non plus dit qu'il fallait en
compte bien l'allemand personnes disent
que je perçois un sourire et l'alcool à
un moment c'était quand même à une
bouteille de chivas par jour je me
souviens - non non c'était chivas
heureusement n'avait pas le permis à
l'époque dit non quand même plus jeune
homme toutes mains tu te rends compte
pourquoi casquette une bouteille de
chivas par jour l'alcootest amélioré par
les pôles question de tournure et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus